Yes. Absolutely. So is a child.
We were twenty four seven plane sports we would play baseball and summer in the football season we would play football.
We would play soccer the family in which I was raised was really all about sports
and I sort of took that passion to a market called the collectibles market so.
When I was a kid I would grass in the summer and then I would take that money and buy baseball cards
and in the winter I was raised in Wisconsin. So I would shovel snow. I would take that money and buy baseball cards.
And from there. I became this kind of this love of the of the sports card market or the baseball card market you.
Are very well that's right. So trading actually gave me an outlet to use sports.
In a market so markets have always fascinated me things like how are prices determined in markets.
You know when I was a little kid we would pay a quarter for a pack of baseball cards
and I wondered why is it a quarter. Why isn't it. Fifty cents why isn't it a dime and those types of questions always.
Peak my curiosity in thinking about how do markets not only price goods but how do they allocate goods
and services to people.
Yes So let's put it this way that I was unusual as a kid I think I had certain quirks that people might. Deny.
It is peculiar or unusual on the one hand I was constantly playing sports
and on the other I had the intellectual curiosity to think deeply about questions like allocations
and markets without calling it that I thought about grocery stores
and trading markets in ways I think that my colleagues when I was Little did not really have the same thoughts.
Yeah I think that's right. I think in the end.
We end up chasing our dreams
and if we're good enough to do the things that we love then we can make that an occupation or a career. That's right.
Is as I grew older through high school and when I was in college.
I began to be a dealer in these markets so what a dealer does is a dealer brings his
or her sports cards to the market in and sells them or trades them to people
and what you could readily see is that not all people were getting the same deal.
Some people would pay a lot more money than another person
and even in those types of markets you could see the inequities that were arise in and I always thought.
What are the factors that are causing those inequities and markets
and what can we do within a free market system to lessen those in equities or make markets more fair.
Well it could be a simple. Women tend to shy away from by.
So what happens in these types of bargaining in markets is that the dealers understand that women shy away from bargain
in so they charge some higher prices and it happens in the used car market it happens in the baseball card market.
It happens in any market where you have bilateral exchange in you have people bargaining over the price that's a severe
inequity that can determine consumption and in concert.
Concerning outcomes of people that are really important like in the labor market. I was pretty good trader.
So just about every weekend.
My girlfriend at the time who became my wife she
and I would go to these large sports car shows we would drive from Madison Wisconsin all the way down to Chicago.
And we would buy sell and trade through time and through experimentation.
I became pretty good at it and I understood kind of what people wanted and how they wanted to bargain
and saw in the long run I think I did pretty well.
I had my experiences so there were some occasions where I was taken advantage of.
I can remember one case where I was trading in a very large trade for me at the time maybe a thousand
or two thousand dollars and I got in return a bunch of counterfeit cards and that that's her bum me out.
I think it's fair to say that I was taken a fool that particular day in the market. They were just fake cards.
That's right. So I've never done that.
Personally I went when I when I buy sell and trade I try to predict what will be good in the future.
So what is a down sports card today.
Hey that will have future value for people in that's the that's the game that I like to play.
I like to play the trading game where I can predict the assets that will increase in value over time I will accumulate
those in then trade them back later.
What I do I see markets fundamentally as a game
but a very important game not a game that is is meant to be nonsensical game
or a trivial game markets tend to be two player games where there is a buyer and there is a seller
or there is an exchange of information and once we understand the rules of this game this market transaction.
Then we can try to optimize what we're trying to do many times people try to optimize their consumption.
According to how much income they have that's a particular consumption game so to speak
and then markets tend to be zero sum games where your gain is my loss
and my gain is your loss in many times markets are set up like that.
It's a very serious game in many cases it's a life or death game markets are
but nevertheless if we think about it in the nomenclature of unknowing men
or mash in many cases it can be modeled is a theory of games
and those theories tell us what our optimal action should be in this market.
A player in only the best sense that there's a negative connotation about a player
but I'm certainly an active market participant and a player in these markets
and I'd like to think of myself as an active participant in.
In the creation of scientific knowledge and we're in a we're in a market constantly you
and I are in a market right now where exchanging information science is also a market.
It's also a game in the sense that there are suppliers and demanders of the scientific knowledge and. In that way.
I consider myself a creator of knowledge and disseminate knowledge. She comes. She. I think that's right.
I think that when markets are poorly constructed. You can think about the financial crisis of the last several years.
There are moments that the market players who have market power tend to change the rules of the game
and we have to be very careful that we don't do that.
Otherwise people become distrustful of the game and distrustful of the market
and that's a first step in the wrong direction because markets are beautiful markets create wealth they create
knowledge they create information
and we have to be careful that people trust market outcomes in people come to markets as active participants who will
be happy about
when someone loses they don't of a sudden change the rules of the game so they become winners I think we have to make
sure as practitioners and as scientists that we don't allow this to happen. This is absolutely.
I think in the end everyone deserves a chance through this market or through this game to succeed. You know as.
As children. We don't choose our parents and if we don't set up the education game.
For the education market in a fair way everyone doesn't have a fair chance to succeed
and I'm fundamentally opposed to people not having a fair chance to succeed in life.
Well
when I first studied economics the very first book that I opened up was written by Paul Samuelson who is one of the most
famous economist of the twentieth century
and Bill Nordhaus who is one of the most famous economists working on Climate Change in
and I was struck by a passage in that book. It said economists cannot run experiments because the world is dirty.
They must therefore sit back like a meteorologist in allow the data to come to them.
In then they can analyze the data using statistical techniques to try to say something causal about the data that's
kind of the way the world was in the late eighty's and early ninety's when I was an undergraduate and graduate student.
And I always thought that was wrong.
Because it's not that I disagreed with them about the world being a very dirty place it is there are multiple markets
there are millions and millions of people millions and millions of firms
and prices in the world is very very Massey So it's not.
It's not like that test tube that the chemist has I think that was their intuition is that the chemist needs a pristine
test tube to run an experiment. So they said look is economist's the world isn't clean.
It's not a sterile test tube so we can't run experiments. I came and I thought much to.
Certainly than that I thought that the sports card markets where I see Konami accent work and I go in
and test economic theory in those markets even though those markets are very dirty they're not clean test tubes.
If I could use randomization Now what I mean by that is I put some people in a treatment group say they get the
cholesterol pill and some people in the control group say they get the sugar pill.
Now all of that dirt is balanced across the treatment of control groups I'm not getting rid of it
but I'm balancing it across treatment control and that allows me to say something causal about the cholesterol pill.
So in a way when I was a graduate student. Absolutely.
I wanted to change the rules of the game I wanted to change the way.
Economists to their empirical work instead of being passive observers have the data come to us and then beat it up
and try to say something cause all I wanted to be an active participant in a market and go in generate my own data.
In generate my own data for a reason to test economic theory and then to change the world about a specific policy
and why do people discriminate Why do people give to charitable causes. Why do inner city schools continue to fail.
These big scientific and social questions are what I want to go after and I want to change the rules of the game
and collect my own data and generate my own data to answer these questions. Thinking. Absolutely.
I mean the the traditional way in which economist
and social scientists more generally think about doing empirical work is they have an idea.
Might be ways in which we can increase people's effort in labor markets.
Then they raced back to their office and they write down a theoretical model and it's a beautiful theoretical model.
In then they say to themselves. How can I test that model many times they don't even test it.
They just write it down and send it out to the world. It's beautiful.
Sometimes they say I want to test the implications of that model.
So what they do is they download mounds and mounds of dad say from the Internet
and then they beat that data up until the Submit since says here's what I say
but they have to impose a lot of statistical assumptions on those data.
To go from a correlation to something that's causal that's the typical way in which scientists have traditionally done
research it down a model go get mounds and mounds of data that somebody else has collected
or the world gives to them beat it up say something about the model. No I do things a little bit differently.
I write down a theory but then I go out in generate data that are meant to test set theory.
So it's a very good fit with the theory itself rather than a misfit rather than put in a square peg where around
when should be which is many times what you're doing when you go out and get the data that the world has given you.
It sounds like science. I think that field experiments have the promise to make.
Economics into what some people would say is a proper science I think for years.
Not only myself but other social scientists have been deemed as soft as a not doing real science.
I think it's fair to say that with field experiments economists now have their full fledged scientific cards.
There are absolutely. Absolutely.
Yeah I think on the one hand behavioral economics might be thought of as a great marketing tool because for decades.
Economists have been interested in behavioral economics you can go all the way back to Adam Smith who talked about.
The moral Hector on the shoulder and doing the right thing.
People don't get that from his most popular book but he has a second book that is very behavioral.
You can go all the way through the twentieth century you had John Maynard Keynes who's very behavioral you had Gary
Becker one of my heroes at the University of Chicago who was very behavioral he was talking about why people
discriminate.
Why do people have Ultra Stick preferences
but then there was this explosion with the work of Danny condom in in Amos Tversky in the seventy's in Dick Thaler in
the eighty's in economics where. We didn't need to invent behavioral economics again because after these pioneers.
Everyone knew what behavioral economics was what which essentially is now to add in psychology
or insights from another discipline into the economic model.
I think you could view it is
and in some humanity to the economics man which I think is right in the moment that you add behavioral economics
or psychology or or let's just say.
Common sense to the economics man we can understand her a little bit more than we could with with the straight sterile
model of neoclassical economics because you know that's right.
I think that was a mistake for many years and in which many people did separate the model from the person and.
People became not very interested in questions about why people did things I think the moment you start to economic
science many times people simply want to measure.
So they measure how much discrimination there is on a market where they measure. What is what is the.
Gender pay gap or the difference between men and women in markets
and then they stop where I think behavioral economics and field experiments allows you to go to the next level
and say why do people discriminate.
Why do women earn less money than men in markets
and it's only after we answer the why's can we first of all know what model is at work and secondly.
We can then put forward public policies to combat the injustices that are done in the world. Only after we know why.
I think by doing field experiments it's the best possible way to not only measure.
For example does discrimination exist in a market but also to distinguish wide as discrimination occur in the market.
I can think of no other tool. That is better than running a field experiment to figure out why.
People are doing what they're doing. You know well let's talk a little bit about that.
So let's let's use the example of discrimination. So in the late one nine hundred fifty S.
An economist named Gary Bakker at the University of Chicago did a dissertation on the economics of discrimination
and his model was based on the simple premise that some people have a preference for discrimination
and what that means is they derive satisfaction of harming another group.
So for example they might not like women or they might not like man
or they might not like old gray haired people like me
or they might not like people of certain races so they treat them poorly they don't hire them for jobs they give them
higher price quotes in used car markets for example
and his model was basically one of people had a taste for discrimination.
So that's one kind of discrimination that's of course abysmal we don't want that another kind of discrimination is what
put goo in all the economist called Third Degree price discrimination in what that was.
Was People discriminate in markets. Not because they dislike the other person but because they want to make more money.
So for example. I might charge women more money in a market because I know they don't like to bargain.
It's not that I dislike women. I just like money and I want to make money for myself.
So now these two theories are very different on the one hand you have backer who says.
People discriminate because they want to cater their prejudice in fact they will give up money to harm another group
and you have another theory that says whoa whoa whoa. Wait a moment people discriminate been effort to make more money.
Very different very different implications in the public policy is to take on these two are very different.
You can think of quotas and the like over here to take on better type discrimination.
Now with poor good type discrimination can take of education and giving people the right tools and bargaining in or
or in information or education to take on that two very different types of discrimination in till we know.
What is happening in markets we cannot even begin to put forward a public policy to take on those bits of
discrimination and that's why field experiments are so important because they tell us the whys whos right back
or most of my data would suggest be good is right. But.
Nevertheless now we know and we can take that on with public policies. Yeah. Let me ask you have salute Lisa this this.
This research we should kind of back ourselves up and ask.
Let's look at the data from labor markets and compare men and women in when we do that all around the globe.
You have men making in say between ten and forty percent more than women.
And then you start to control for things like occupation. Human capital.
Time out of the labor force and you still have a significant difference say now.
It's five to fifteen percent and then we must ask ourselves what is causing that difference.
And what can we do to get rid of that difference. Now.
There were some researchers called early Guinea's E N L though Rusty Keeney and Marian need early
and Lisa Vester the one who started to do lab experiments to explore what could underlie these differences
and they were beginning to find that men were more competitive than women. So this is where I step in ask.
And we generalize those insights into the field and explore what are the implications.
In the field in real markets for this difference in preferences.
OK so where I started was I said why do men and women have different preferences for being competitive.
So I looked all around the globe and this is where the early going.
Izzie and cannot in my two co-authors
and we said can we find two societies that are diametrically opposed in terms of the power that the woman has in the
household and in the society. And we came pretty close.
We found one very patriarchal society in Tanzania called the Messiah tribe.
And under close to the other end of the spectrum was a major lineal society called the Cassy society
and what we did is we simply went out to those two societies and took the simple experiments from the lab
and tried to replicate those in the field and our first result is.
The differences across the societies were really enormous when you talk to people in the Messiah tribe in Tanzania.
In you ask a messiah man. What is your wealth.
What he'll tell you is I have fourteen head of cattle three donkey two sheep and four wives.
And he says if I want another wife I have to trade seven head of cattle because that's a current price.
While only right that women have as their husband has to visit them for fifteen minutes every morning in their tent.
That's the rights that women have really really a terrible society for with no one near the other end of the spectrum
are the Cassie's who.
When you when you jump in a cab from the airport and go out to the villages in in red outside a show long.
You see these billboards that they keep saying the same thing in the taxi cab driver after you ask the taxi cab driver
what. What do these billboards say he says of. It's those men again they're asking for equal rights.
So you have close to the other side of society where if you knock on the door of a Cassie a met the man will answer
and he will take you back to the woman of the house.
And then you will talk to the woman about the issues of the day the woman who will make market decisions
and will make decisions for the family.
You know it's gotten to the point where many Cassy men will say something like we're sick of playing the role of
breeding bulls and babysitters.
So these are these are very different societies
and what we do is we run the simple experiments in these two societies in what we find is that the Tanzanians are a lot
like us in the U.S. and In Western Europe the men compete a lot more than the women compete.
Now when we go to the Cassie's what happens is that reverses the Cassy women compete.
Eat like our man and the Cassie man compete roughly about like our women.
So this gives you a sense it's a beginning first step.
It's certainly not the final word
but it's a beginning first step to get to the point of what causes these differences and preferences
and I think this literature in our study is point to the power of socialization.
And when we raise our little boys
and girls what subtle words that we say to them subtle gifts that we give them have lasting impacts into the future.
I can still remember. When I was in second or third grade.
I was feeling ill one day
and I wasn't performing in my physical education class in my gym class I wasn't doing as well is what I usually do.
Do you know what the teacher yells out to me Hey John. Hey John.
Quit playing like a sissy you're playing like a girl today.
He had in his mind that girl should play a certain way in boys should play a certain way
and that's exactly how we're typically socialized and I think that importantly determines our long run outcomes.
Now our next step in this research agenda was to create a firm and hire workers
and actually put out ads across United States to hire IT Ministry of assistance this is work with Andres labor and
and what we explored is if we change the incentive scheme.
From one where we tell people wages are negotiable to another one where we have the exact same ad.
But we don't say wages are negotiable. And then we look at whether men and women.
First of all apply in then whether they negotiate and what we find is that when we say Wade. Edges are negotiable.
Many many women apply and they negotiate as much as men. Now when we leave that sentence out of the job description.
What happens is women shy away from applying and they shy away from negotiating
and in fact the men negotiate a lot more than the women when that aspect is ambiguous
and what that tells us is that in these M.
Big us who vegs settings women are taught to shy away from asking because they don't know if it's appropriate where men
in our experiment was actually the low quality men who came forward in the bargain the most so men are taught to be
aggressive as boys and go after what you deserve. So then they do it in markets and you have these inequities.
But I think that's right.
When you look at the way our economy is set up the the highest pain jobs are the ones that are the most competitive.
They're the ones that you build your way up the pyramid in then when you're at the top.
It's highly competitive because your firm is competing against another firm that is altered competitive
and the world is a place of competition but my argument is that. If we can set up.
The wage schemes in the rules of the game in a way in which we recognize that society is handicapped in certain types
of people. If we set up the rules of the game at the entry level.
This can systematically affect where these two types of people go in the long run and market.
It's look many things are extremely competitive The question is should we set up our wages in our house.
We pay people in a competitive way.
Or are there ways in which we can set up wage contracts that get people to perform at their highest levels
but they're not cutthroat wages.
You see and and I don't think is economists
or policy makers we have thought hard about setting up the rules of the game in a way that will give everyone a fair
chance but will still lead to really good outcomes.
Because right now you have a lot of lost human talent because women shy away from the set ins
or a lot of women who are very very talented who shy away from settings that are too competitive so we're essentially
wasting their human capital because of the manner in which our wage contracts are set up that's what I'm saying.
I think something can be done.
One example is my study that I just talked about where if we're very clear about the rules of the game
and how people should negotiate they will then negotiate as hard is they should
and they will start out with wages that are much more equal than they otherwise would be.
Women should just negotiate say that you know some of the implications from our studies when we go overseas
and look at behavior in major lineal societies what you have is women are much gentle or with the resources.
We've been given here on Earth.
For example when we look at men and women farm in a run in in Iran Chalong what you see is that
when women have the choices about what crops to plant and how to rotate their crops they tend to be much kinder
and gentler to the soil. Than what. The men will be so in this way you have some indications that on some dimensions.
We would be much better off having the gentle touch of a woman. Absolutely. If.
I think they are playing very different games I think men are playing name a much shorter run game over there in women
are playing in the long run game that we need to continue to that say nurture this land
and it's going to be ours for a long time in we want to live in a symbiotic way where the man might just discount the
future a little bit more than women and they're playing a different fundamental market game in
and in this case farming game than women are. Yes that's right that's right. That's right.
So my work in education started about a decade ago.
There's a local community around Chicago called Chicago Heights and they came to me with a plea.
They had read about some of my work in the New York Times magazine on charitable giving.
So I work a little bit on the economics of charity why people give to charitable causes
and they wondered if I could come into their school district and help them
and I visited the school district a few days later and what I found was.
A school district that was in very difficult shape.
They were they had two high schools and they had about a thousand kids entering the ninth grade each year and all.
The About four hundred seventy of them were graduating from high school.
So you had this community that was largely in trouble with its public education.
So we began to use field experiments to try to learn about why that inner city school was failing.
And in the last ten years. I have been thinking hard about using Chicago Heights is my laboratory.
And in this sense it's a field experimental laboratory that is meant first of all to test economic theory.
So we have different theories about what's called the Education production function.
You know how do the inputs such as children's effort parents Safford in teacher effort map into outcomes that we care
about outcomes like finishing high school outcomes like going to college outcomes like it in a high paying job outcomes
like. Being a better citizen. In our global community.
So we started thinking hard about how those inputs affected the outputs that we cared about
and then also how can we change those inputs.
How can we fundamentally change the effort levels of parents
or how can we fundamentally change the effort levels of children or or teachers or administrators. Absolutely.
So this is markets now again. Now when I started this research.
I thought hard about what do we know in public education because in the US We've been at public education for over one
hundred years you should say we should know a lot but I think public education got caught in this rut.
Whereby they more or less took this Mark Twain quote is once you have.
Ignorance and confidence then success is insured so I think people were ignorant
and confident that they knew what was happening.
And then for years here in the States especially our public education system was broken
and I think it's fundamentally because we use our classrooms to simply teach our kids.
We don't use our classrooms to teach our kids and teach ourselves what works and why.
And I think we need to change that mentality because this is life or death. Much like medicines.
You know in the medical community we figure out which drugs work by testing them by using science in testing whether a
heart medication works better than another heart medication better than the control group which receives a sugar pill.
I fundamentally don't understand why we don't take that mentality to the classroom
and all around the world we should be using our classrooms as laboratories laboratories of innovation to figure out
what works. Why does it work and how can we make the world a better place through education because fundamentally.
You know it is I said before we don't choose parents.
We don't choose a community in which we're born into and if we don't give these kids in equal chance to succeed.
We are leaving so much human potential on the table. We've talked a lot about equity here.
Equity is giving everyone a fair chance in life and that's important but you can also talk about efficiency.
I don't think we've wasted.
This much human potential since the Dark Ages
when you look at our technology that we have in place around the world in you look at all of the human potential that
we're wasting. Because kids are not receiving proper education. That's a crime.
That's a real crime
and it's because we have not been serious about using field experiments in the classroom to learn about what works
and why. So what kind of the.
Yes So in Chicago Heights in the last decade we've been running in a number of field experiments
and let me tell you about one with teachers so. For decades.
People have argued about whether teachers should be paid for their performance so.
Some people say if a teacher does a really good job with her students.
Then she should get paid a bonus but there are people say. No no no we don't want to add money.
To this equation because great teachers. Don't value money they value teaching per se.
So some people have gone out
and they've explored a typical way in which to pay a teacher a bonus what they've said is in September.
They tell teachers that if you do a good job.
You will be paid a bonus next June at the end of the school year and by and large they haven't really found.
Very promising results and they have been small
and in consequential So that's a place where we started we said Can we start there
and use behavioral economics to make the incentive better.
So our idea was what if we took a group of teachers in in September we actually gave them the bonus upfront
and told them.
We will take the bonus away from you in less your students achieve if your students achieve you can keep the bonus if
they don't achieve. We will take it away from you and what happens is that incentive scheme.
Works in a brilliant way is an example if your child was placed in the classroom of a teacher who received that claw
back incentive scheme. They their test scores.
Actually it Vance by about what's called Point two standard deviations above the control group which turned out to be
several months of education.
So you're basically getting several months of extra education because the teacher is in this claw back incentive scheme.
Now you might ask yourself why does that club back incentive scheme work.
We can go back to the days of Dan economy and Amos to versity they wrote about something called loss aversion
and what that means is that people value losses much more than they value comparable gains.
So a dollar loss is felt much more acutely than a dollar again. So we're leveraging that insight if you use it.
Introspection and say. I'm I like that many of us are like that we really do not like losses.
So can we leverage that is a public policy tool we found we can we found that teachers will work a lot harder if you
leverage loss aversion. Now we've done this. Also in other venues too.
We've gone to China and we've looked at Chinese manufacturing workers in we've used the exact same incentive scheme.
We've said at the beginning of the week. Here's a bonus. And if you work hard on Friday.
You can keep that bonus in we compare that to the idea that work hard all week will give you a bonus on Friday loss
aversion one works a lot better
and in fact we did the one in China over a six month period over all six months the manufacturing workers worked hard.
Or
when they were getting the bonus Up front this is a useful way to leverage behavioral economics to make the world a better
place. Yes We actually did the same with students as well.
So you might ask yourself how can I make my child work hard for experiments with students is the morning of the test
when they enter the room where they take the test. We announce to them.
Here's twenty dollars if you perform better than you did on your last test you can keep the twenty dollars if you don't
perform better.
We will take the twenty dollars away
and what happens is those students significantly increase their test scores in an amount that you cannot even imagine
compared to people who we tell them we will give you twenty dollars if you perform well.
Those people perform much worse than people who you give the twenty dollars to.
We did we then saw the teacher results and we said.
Will that work with students we did a little bit differently with students.
We had them and to the test room and then after they entered the test room.
We announced our incentives so they did not have time to prepare.
We were just looking at the morning of the test can we give them incentives in leverage loss aversion
and get them to try harder and perform better on the test.
So what we did is we gave a big group of students twenty dollars
and said If you perform better than you did on the last test you can keep the twenty dollars in we compared their test
scores to people who we said if you improve on your test score from last time you will receive twenty dollars.
What happens is
when you give students twenty dollars they perform much much better than if you tell them you'll receive twenty dollars
in the future.
That's of I think it's a very important insight about what our task measure when you
when you look at these standardized tests they're not only measuring in name.
Debility they're also measuring in effort. Oh or how hard students try on these tests. Why.
Yeah I think the underlying reason why loss aversion works is because people develop a deep pain
or a distaste for something that they have to give up.
So my own research that started back in two thousand and three in the sports card market.
I tried to explore why do people not like to trade.
Why do people not like to give something up in what I found back then was it looked like it was a pain of giving
something up. That's why people did not like to give up or trade what they owned.
So now recently what we've done is we've placed people in F. M.R.I.
Tubes and we've looked at their brain activity
and we've explored really inexperienced people in what their brain activity looks like compared to people who have a
lot of experience in trading in people who trade a lot.
They tend to code trades in a different part of the brain than people who are inexperienced traders in particular the
people who are experienced Do not go to the last part of the brain in people who are inexperienced go to the last part.
when they have to give something up. So it's sort of uncovers through the market and through F. M.R.I.
Or imaging of the brain. It tells you why people when they gain experience why they can trademark. It. Absolutely.
I think the major reason why markets work is because people trade.
You have people who trade by definition the seller gains in the buyer gains through a trade.
So if we can contemplate why there's a lack of trading and markets we can figure out why doesn't the market.
Work the way it should we can then design incentives to get people to trade more in markets.
What we find is that there is not enough trade in in markets
or the market gains are smaller than they should be because of loss aversion.
So what can we do to make the market function more appropriately.
My argument is you have to give them a sense of overcoming loss aversion
and that's through market experience so you have to give them trades and give them. Let's say free trade.
So to speak and once people trade in trade in trade. They don't have loss of us preferences anymore.
That's how we can use it to make markets better. Yes.
I think if we somehow change the rules to make people want to trade more
when they're first enter a market the market can be more efficient in the end that's right.